Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Walking Dead episode
five video.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet here we go.
Jesus is back I'm so happy he's one of my
favorite characters on The Walking Dead, just
because of the way he's able to lighten the
tone, but still be a bad ass like he has mad
skills, but things have been so dire for the
last couple of episodes you just need somebody
to lighten the tension.
So Jesus monster truck rallies to the rescue
let's do top 10 WTF and comic book Easter
Eggs there couple really big comic book arcs
that they're setting up I'll just try to deal
with the stuff that they did in this episode.
And if they do end up doing stuff from later
in the comics we can talk about it in the
episodes where it happens but number 10 Maggie
still alive.
As expected, this is a comic book thing like
she had some trauma with her baby in the comics
but as she's fine in this episode.
Same thing happens in the comics the doctors
like you know you maybe had some trauma like
he has no idea what happened with Glenn and
Abraham, but the number nine Sasha buries
them out back and she takes Glenn's watch
which is actually Herschel's lays it down,
but everybody's favorite douche bag walks
in Gregory and if you forgot about him from
season six he's basically like the feckless
leader of hilltop complete pushover.
But as he says during the episode oh I got
a right where I want him.
I'm totally dealing with the situation but
really they're just trying to set up somebody
else taking over, so they really wanted you
to hate him in this episode so things are
all proceeding according to comic book plan
he's mostly just worried about what the savers
are gonna do when they find out that they
help them number eight the saviors rollout
a big show monster truck rally time it was
so hilarious when you know number seven at
the end of the episode Maggie explained where
she learned that trick though there was this
guy in high school and I laugh so hard when
Enid asked her if it was the guy that she
ran over like oh you reign over the guy with
your car know know know I ran over his Camaro,
but don't you just love Maggie that much more
knowing that she did that when she was in
high school like that's how bad as she was
dead number seven.
I think what they're implying is that Maggie
will eventually take leadership of hilltop
like when Jesus was talking to them at the
end of the episode and said that he had somebody
else in mind like and when he first came in
Gregory was in charge and he couldn't imagine
anyone else taking the job, so I think what
he was implying is is that he's eventually
going to ask Maggie to step up just because
she seems like such a strong person when Deanna
was still alive actually foreshadowed little
bit of this like she asked Maggie to work
with her can learn how to administrate the
group.
So Maggie's been learning to be a leader for
a while now.
So the ark she's on is a little bit clear
like she's this strong single mom who is now
going to be this very strong leader of eventually
number six Gregory is going to be like the
puppet leader for the time being he's in charge
of effectively but he's not in charge.
Those with Jesus is whole speech was about.
He was standing up to him look.
This is the way it's going to be there staying
that's it.
But number five back to the save zone so I
should have felt like the Carl storyline was
a little crazier, just because of what it
was implying but number five Rick and was
shown sidetrip michonne seems like she might
run into the kingdom Rick they tease might
run into another group from the comics but
it's not the whisperers, there's a lot of
talk about the whispers this past week.
But they weren't saying they were coming on
this season.
They just said they will be coming on sooner
rather than later I think the big thing though,
even though were gonna see all these different
groups is that the survivors themselves will
remain split up even though they might see
Carol there that doesn't mean that Carol will
come back with them and it seems like Maggie
and Sasha are staying put it hilltop for now
to, so the group is more fractured than ever
before I get to the Carl stuff I'll say you
know number four is Simon in his performance
with Gregory he's the new Negan you might
hear people call him Trevor.
Just make that joke because he's the same
actor in real life that does the character
Trevor in Grand Theft Auto.
So even though his name is Simon on The Walking
Dead like when you hear people referring to
him as Trevor.
That's what they're talking about but he does
have the crazy performance being the new Negan
of hilltop over those last people you dealt
with they were taken a kinda soft on you.
So he's kind of trying to do his best Negan
impersonation he's doing a pretty good job
of it to but the problem is is that even though
Negan is every bit this ass hole he is way
more terrifying and he has some of the muscle
and the weaponry to back it up to Negan could
actually throw down if he needed to but I
would be willing to bet that Sasha could take
Simon if she really wanted to, but she would
have a much harder time if she were to try
to take Negan on directly which doesn't give
you a lot of hope for Carl's mission, so number
three Carl goes after Enid on a Sunday drive
I just feel felt like going for a drive you
could make the joke that he's a terrible driver
because he has no depth perception but he
probably would've done that anyway, but is
still pretty funny just super casual.
Just ran in the car around is destroying everything
but if you forgot about the big reference
they dropped to the previous season so when
he locked her in the armory and she was like
I didn't need to see it.
That was when they went to take Maggie to
hilltop and she was talking about having to
watch Glenn and Abraham died so she could
you tell Carl I'm sorry you had to see it
was not all a huge bummer because they find
that pair skates have like a really brief
moment of just being kids for Carl opens up
and explains I'm gonna kill Negan.
You know number two Carl plot line from the
comics he plans to kill Negan.
In fact, these mattresses that he's hiding
under are the mattresses that the saviors
burned in that previous episode that was what
was shown was so pissed about and in a crying
at the end of the episode that burning pile
of mattresses the saviors of take it so slight
change from the comics but that's what you're
looking at right here so we can follow that
along with the episodes all talk about the
comic book stuff as we see it but he says
the exact same thing.
He undertakes the exact same type of mission
in the comics but the difference is is the
comic book Carl is way smaller's was even
more of a WTF and speaking of which know number
one just like that final end tag where Jesus
is jumping on the back of the truck and sees
Carl and just casually gives him a what's
up like it's no big deal but there on the
back of a truck headed to hell, let me know
what was your favorite moment from the episode
there were a lot of nice tags like Herschel's
watch like that's a nice object is kind of
followed the characters around like Herschel
gave it to Glenn.
Now Maggie gave it to Enid, there's this whole
theme about letting go get of burning the
bodies versus bearing them remembering things.
Maggie comes to the conclusion like the right
conclusion I think that she's able to let
the stuff go and move forward because we have
each other.
Carl is the other side of that he cannot let
this go.
That is why he's on this crackpot mission
to go kill Negan, but at least you have Jesus
there.
I think they did that in the episode.
Just so you wouldn't feel so bad for him to
be gone by himself, there's actually no way
this would've gone well but with Jesus there.
He might be able to help Carl out a little
bit.
So I think they wanted you to be a little
bit more hopeful, especially up as you hear
Sasha sharpening her knife smoking Abraham
cigar there but that which is another great
way to let you know that the survivors people
like Sasha are just gonna be sitting around
letting the saviors come take half of their
stuff every single week.
So the Hilltop stuff the Carl stuff right
out of the comics can't wait to see where
they go with it if is any other Easter eggs
you guys spotted that I didn't mention just
let me know in the comments below.
I really feel like Maggie is going to benefit
from this season of walking that the most
she's gonna get one of the best character
arcs as well.
As Carl at least in comparison to his arcs
in previous seasons he's always been something
of a supporting character but now I did a
really try to do something interesting and
thanks to the comics that's actually pretty
easy to do.
But I did just hear a really crazy Chandler
Riggs rumor.
So if you guys want me to do a video about
that later this week that is just a rumor
right now but what can happen next is I'll
be doing new Westworld in a new Walking Dead
Trailer.
So be sure to subscribe to get that stuff
in there is new Walking Dead giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so those
of the videos will start posting early tomorrow
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn about Emilia Clarke from
Game of Thrones being in the new Star Wars
Han Solo movie can click here for my Westworld
video.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!